hey guys this is andrew for joining
census.com so very quickly let me
introduce myself because this is youtube
this is how it's working
i'm a professional trader and i've just
started to make youtube videos
where i basically try to talk about
everything i know everything i see at
work
all the different tools and techniques
that i use to make money on the markets
so in today's video i want to make an
update on amc
let's get into it
all right guys so this is amc charts
let's start on the first time frame and
let's see
what we can find i have actually
some new information to give you what i
was
actually expecting which is basically
here we moved up
you know from february to march
strongly with a beautiful one two three
four five then we
recorrected with an abc and i was
expecting a third wave just like four
game stop
and the third wave is not coming guys
you know this is a fact
we cannot ignore it so we need to adapt
and we need to understand what is
happening
and it's actually those two stocks they
move together i do like
very like regular uh updates on those
two
and usually when something is true for
one it's true for the other one
and here guys we i was telling you about
this wxy correction many times for those
who have watched my video you know
that this was a scenario i had in mind
it was not my preferred scenario
because i was seeing some you know
bullishness coming i was seeing that we
had some nice breakouts
we had some nice breakouts here guys on
the 14th of april i gave you this
breakout we had here a beautiful
bullish development and then you know we
have this
bearish week guys that you know
is almost ending you're gonna see i'm
probably gonna have one day
delay on this video because i posted
gamestop yesterday and i
actually did those two video on the same
day so as you can see guys we are just
check
here guys so you know that i'm telling
you the truth
we are here i'm using the fifth of may
closing level and we are for me you can
see here we are the sixth
of may so whatever here what is
happening guys is that actually we
having this
sideways correction this is a complex
correction and i'm going to explain like
i did for gamestop how you can actually
go towards this
kind of conclusion before it is finished
because once it's finished it is useless
to actually say oh in the past we had
this complex correction that went
sideways
when something is messy this is not
messy one two three four five this is
beautiful this is the very clean
counting so when you have something that
is clean that is going
up you know with all the indicators
going together maggie going up
volume speaking up you know this is
giving you
the trend the trend is bullish then we
having this correction
abc for now it is still clean right
at this time so i was kind of
convinced that we're having here the
third wave but the move
down that we had here is telling me that
something else is happening and i don't
know what
so you need to accept that there is
something that is uh playing at
that is not very clear and usually when
this is the case
when you don't know what is happening
when you cannot do a clean counting when
you know everything is not going towards
the same direction
it is usually a complex correction so
you go towards the double threes
the triple threes the w x y the w x
y z this is you know something that you
find
here in this is idiot wave book you can
find it on the internet you just have
idiots
wave principle trash turn frost and
double and triple threes i'm not going
to read this again like i did for
gamestop but go check my video on yum
stuff guys
i went through this into details and
it's just explaining to you how this is
working all right so i'm going to
explain this as well in the new training
that i'm going to do
soon giving you like clear examples but
basically what we're having is something
like this w
x y w x y you know it can be abcs it can
be triangle whatever
and this here is to me what is playing
out and the only rule that it needs to
uh respect
is that it is moving sideways and using
the classic
corrective patterns let's see if we can
find it abc
easy here abc going higher and now we
just did the a
wave guys so the a wave is about to stop
as you can see here we're having let's
go to hourly timeframe
we're having some consolidation all
right
this is a consolidation going lower
higher lower
so this is consolidating around the nine
level let's see if this was predictable
as usual guys you know bam
and you see right on its tank
support so here we having a support
level definitely
this is now resistance this is our
major resistance level this is what we
want to break to finish the a wave
all right the a wave is going to be
finished when we're going to break the
orange line here on the hourly time
frame so basically when we're going to
trade above
uh say 950 when amc is going to trade
above 950 we're gonna have something
like this and then probably go lower
because
then we would have completed the complex
correction
that is happening right now so let's
analyze a bit what
happened here at this level and if this
was actually possible to find why
did we actually rebound here the same
reason why we rebounded at 980
but actually 980 didn't hold at all it
was
just a little bit rebound then we blew
right through it then we come back
rejected and we go over all right so 980
has not
hold long now we we are at the nine
as you can see guys this is working for
a long time
this level so here is the lowest level
then here you can see we have
some resistance we break it ruby test
so this is a major level now that is
acting as
support once twice three four five
six seven eight 9
10 all right in the very recent past it
acted 10 times as
support or resistance on the hourly time
frame so this is our strong support and
i'm expecting it to
hold and once again are looking for this
kind of development
then we're probably going to do the b
wave and the c wave and this would have
complete
our w x y complex corrective pattern
and then we're gonna probably be ready
to move for the third
wave very quickly let me give you a bit
more information
so what do we have on the option market
so the option market as usual guys you
know what i do
i take all the options i can that they
can find on your finance
i just you know store it here and i do
my
charts i compute you know all the
synthetic short
using the delta formula that is here you
know it's always the same thing guys you
know it's this formula
and the delta is actually it's this
formula guys as you can see
so it is not that complicated to do it
looks like a bit
long but it's actually quite simple so
you guys can do it as well
if you want you know it's quite easy and
once you get the delta
once you get so first you need to get
the volatility that you can find on your
finance then
you have the delta and then you can you
can compute the
synthetic short interest associated to
each call
option once you get this you can compute
the total synthetic short that is just
the sum
of the synthetic shot by strike and here
what you can see
now i go on the september maturity
because i think that it's more stable
and i'm going to monitor this volatility
for now 164 percent which is very high
of course for the for the strike
and the delta for the
september maturity the delta is 29
guys so there is 30 chance that amc
trades above
40 in september so this is you know the
information that is given to you by the
option market
this is not my view this is the reality
there is a probability it's like when
bookmakers you know give you
a nod you can say that it's a
probability for example if it's like
you know 50 50 you know the fight or you
the match you're gonna watch
is gonna be very even here we we have 30
chance given by the bookmakers that are
option market marketers actually
that is 30 of amc trading above
fully in september so it's a lot guys
all right
you need to accept that you know this is
big
and this is one of the reason why i am
so bullish i'm just
reading the information content here
let's have a quick look
at the short interest information so the
synthetic shot is back to five percent
on amc
it was six but as you can see guys we
went lower
we are not at ten anymore we are at nine
so it's even four percent guys now
so here i am that my data now it is four
percent as you can see here
and so the dtc one months using the
monthly volume
is 2.3 and the dtc one week using the
weekly volume is much higher because the
volume is very low
so this is also one information that we
are in a corrective pattern
and 3.7 is actually quite high guys
we're getting hot here
so we're getting hard for two reasons
because uh hedge funds are selling more
you can see that in the last two weeks
they sold 20 million more shares on the
market
so the short interest rest is 23 i add
on top of that with my
synthetic short and we're having a 27
percent total short interest which is a
lot
so it's gonna take in average almost
four days to cover
uh if they want to cut their position so
they're going to start thinking about it
if amc goes higher so once again we need
to be in the third wave which is going
to come
before all this data would actually
enter
in the game and create this bullish
momentum we are waiting
for so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys